that's Prince Charles forgetting not to
shake hands amid concerns over the
coronavirus the 71 year old royal
extended his hand before quickly
withdrawing it not once but twice upon
arriving at the Prince's Trust Awards
Wednesday afternoon I wanted to offer my
heartfelt congratulations on this
occasion to all those astonishing young
people to be recognized Charles was a
good sport and laughed off his first
boat on
and check out his quick recovery into a
namaste gesture after slipping up a
second time and admitting quote it's
just so hard to remember not to
the Prince of Wales demonstrated this
sea move at Monday's Commonwealth Day
service well one of the things that was
so notable about today's service was the
absence of any handshaking and of course
this is because of the the spread of the
corona virus that it was very pointed
that there was no physical contact
Westminster Abbey has been implementing
this policy for the last few weeks
[Music]
Queen Elizabeth opted for a simple head
nod instead and here's Prince Harry
exchanging an elbow bump with performer
Craig David meanwhile Megan Marcos
simply flashed a smile to each attendee
before chatting away and get this the no
handshaking policy also seemed to extend
to the Fab Four's interactions they
didn't really speak that there wasn't
really much of an embrace between them
as we've seen last year it's hard to
know whether that was because of
strained relations or just because of
the situation that we're in at the
moment okay so the iciness between Megan
Harry William and Kate might have been
for different reasons but regardless
both duchesses seemed to throw caution
to the wind when greeting children
waiting outside following the service
and clearly Prince Charles is struggling
with the no physical touch thing too
[Music]